avec nous sur ce plateau nicolas vidal
directeur de publication de putsch
médias bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france on l'a vu cet acte 64
risque d'être contrarié puisque la
préfecture de police elle a donc
interdit la manifestation dans plusieurs
lieux qui correspondent au parcours du
cortège parisien
comment est ce que vous voyez cette
interdiction c'est sûr déjà c'est un
parcours très présomptueux mais au-delà
de ça cet acte 64 c'est le nouvel acte 2
de l'épreuve démocratique ddj les jeunes
face à l'exécutif
et ça je pense que c'est extrêmement
important et et ce parcours je répète
c'est vrai que on se dit bon on va
passer devant tous les lieux de pouvoir
donc la préfecture de fait interdite ce
qui fait qu'ils continuent à faire qu'on
a une opposition très forte cette
acquisition de blocs contre contre c'est
très ponctuel mais contre sur les jeunes
depuis depuis l'acte 64 donc oui c'est
vraiment pour moi une épreuve
démocratique ce nouvel acteur 64 et ce
depuis très longtemps maintenant quand
on fait parallèle avec les
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites pour lesquelles la préfecture
de police autorise les cordages à se
rendre à proximité de lieux sensibles et
ce qu'ils appellent une sorte de façons
de faire différentes lorsqu'il s'agit
des gels et jaune alors oui je vais
apparaître discrimination oui alors
peut-être effectivement c'est des
cortèges on le sait tous qu'ils sont
extrêmement encadrées on ne voit qu'en
ont fait les manifestations on les a
faites aussi on voit que c'est très très
encadré mais met une nouvelle fois je
crois que là on se retrouve dans une
impasse encore plus je vais dit être
sans foi ici on est dans une impasse
totale
et c'est une véritable impasse
démocratique parce qu'on est face à un
pouvoir qui a très bien entendu ce qu'il
en est un qui n'apporte pas les réponses
c'est parce qu'il a peu par steve et
réponses et que sa ligne est claire sa
ligne de politique économique est clair
et ça pouvait ligne politique
néolibérale est claire aussi
donc il se retrouve face à une jambe à
dire allez 60% de la france périphérique
qui aujourd'hui emmanuel macron l'avait
dit d'ailleurs on s'est revu la bbc ce
sont les perdants de la mondialisation
donc à partir ce moment là quand vous
n'avez pas de réponse que le
gouvernement ne veut pas changer de voie
ne veut pas changer de secteur et il
continue à appliquer et on le voit
d'ailleurs la réforme des retraites on
voit que maintenant on léger des jeunes
ont été rejoints par toute une foule de
gens et donc on est toujours dans 7e
passe absolue
mais ce qui me ce qui me pose problème
c'est assez préoccupant pour notre pays
c'est que je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
seule question qui pourrait se poser de
valable pour sortir cette ornière
absolument démocratique
si je l'avais dit la semaine dernière
mais c'est un référendum qu'il faut
voilà je crois que la marge de manoeuvre
aujourd'hui aussi bien chez les jets les
jeunes chez les manifestants les
opposants à la réforme des retraites et
aux surtout en regard du gouvernement la
marge manoeuvre de plus en plus limitées
pour les deux façons on va parler c'est
pas des quand je leur dis ça mais en
face à face à ces deux blocs la marge
brute est de plus en plus limitées et
c'est pour ça que je dis que c'est
extrêmement préoccupant qui elle va
passer demain qui sait après demain et
mêlant art et wendel sur quel cirque
elle pas déjà la réforme des retraites
serait pas mal voilà on pourrait partir
de réforme des retraites
il ya aussi après vous le savez avec le
bright side je fais un petit aparté
rapide 1 mais hier les discours des
manuels macron sur le break site et est
assez stupéfiant il nous a toujours dit
plus de plus d'europe plus d'europe plus
d'europe l'appareil d'euros plus
démocratique il faudrait réfléchir fondé
voir ajustée mais on se rend bien compte
que manuel macron ce discours d'hier vue
sur le break site était extrêmement
intéressant parce que au-delà du break
site
il faut quand même aussi voir que
emmanuel bach qu'on va continuer la
politique d'un train de mettre en place
a atteint 64 dg les jeunes aujourd'hui
vous vous attendiez à ce que le
mouvement dure si longtemps
ben oui forcément je l'avais dit il la
mobilisation ne faiblit pas c'est
évident et il a été poussé avec le
carburant la réforme des retraites je
l'avais déjà dit ici le
réforme des retraites aujourd'hui une
mobilisation c'est le format xxl des
jeunes donc c'est fraîchement la suite
la suite exponentielle de 7,7 vindicte
populaire qui se sentent totalement
déconsidéré par le pouvoir qui met en
place une politique et les gens ont
l'impression effectivement que
l'exécutif le gouvernement est en train
de de gouverner pour des intérêts privés
et c'est le contraire absolu de ce que
doit faire le chef de l'état le chef de
l'état doit gérer le pays ordonné le
pays administré le pays dans l'intérêt
des françaises et des français et c'est
un pascal continuera bien entendu via
leur enlève leurs revendications à
angers les jeunes ont largement évolué
depuis le premier acte il est à 64
semaine oui alors moi je pense qu'ils
ont pas évolué et je pense qu'on a
c'était le latex la taxe diesel puis
surtout moi je continue à le dire en
permanence un la volonté démocratique de
reprendre en main son destin
elle est là depuis le début c'est là
depuis le début donc la volonté
démocratique elle se fait encore plus
jours avec le riz qu'avec le rythme est
ce c'est tout l'émanation du référendum
dire que le peuple français aujourd'hui
et souverain dans son état il veut
décider n'est pas d'accord en majorité
semble-t-il avait la politique du
gouvernement
donc tant qu'on ne redonnera pas la
parole aux français sur des référendum
ça peut être sur l'europe ça peut être
la réforme des retraites ça peut être
une chose ça sort c'est la seule
garantie pour rétablir la paix et la
sérénité la concorde en ce pays c'est la
seule c'est la seule solution
aujourd'hui le mois du rassemblement
parisien dg les jeunes aujourd'hui est
liberté égalité fraternité il faut
s'attendre à des affrontements là dans
les prochaines heures
très sincèrement je n'espère pas je
l'espère pas de son nom le dit tout se
fait à peu près il faut une issue
politique à ceux à sa chute politique on
ne peut pas balayer d'un revers de main
la démocratie cette volonté de volonté
démocratique du peuple français ce n'est
absolument pas possible et ça pose la
question toujours est-ce que je l'aï
posé la semaine dernière c est ce que ce
modèle néolibéral et il fait tilt
société s qui rassemblent suffisamment
de gens pour faire société
il ne nie pas réparé deuxième question
est ce que le modèle néolibéral est il
compatible avec la démocratie c'est une
question que je pose une nouvelle fois
et ça mon avis et c'est la question qui
est centrale merci pour votre regard
nicolas vidal
merci directeur la publication de putsch
médias